Of course you can conceive a few options, like having a drink, writing a letter,
also sleeping during this boring talk,
if you can.
But not all of them.
So think about an alien invasion, now, here, in Milan,
or me -- I stopped thinking for 15 minutes.
So it's very difficult to conceive this space,
but actually we have an excuse.
So it's not so easy to conceive this space
because we are trying to conceive the occurrence of something brand new,
so something that never occurred before,
so we don't have clues.
A typical solution could be
looking at the future with the eyes of the past,
so relying on all the time series of past events
and hoping that this is enough to predict the future.
But we know this is not working.
For instance, this was the first attempt for weather forecasts, and it failed.
And it failed because of the great complexity
of the underlying phenomenon.
So now we know that predictions had to be based on modeling,
which means creating a synthetic model of the system,
simulating this model and then projecting the system
into the future through this model.
And now we can do this in a lot of cases
with the help of a lot of data.
Looking at the future with the eye of the past
could be misleading also for machines.
Think about it.
Now picture yourself for a second in the middle of the Australian Outback.
You stand there under the sun.
So you see something weird happening.
The car suddenly stops
very, very far from a kangaroo crossing the street.
You look closer
and you realize that the car has no driver.
It is not restarting, even after the kangaroo is not there anymore.
So for some reasons,
the algorithms driving the car cannot make sense
of this strange beast jumping here and there on the street.
So it just stops.
Now, I should tell you, this is a true story.
It happened a few months ago to Volvo's self-driving cars
in the middle of the Australian Outback.
(Laughter)
It is a general problem,
and I guess this will affect more and more in the near future
artificial intelligence and machine learning.
It's also a very old problem, I would say 17th century,
but I guess now we have new tools and new clues to start solving it.
So let me take a step back,
five years back.
Italy. Rome. Winter.
So the winter of 2012 was very special in Rome.
Rome witnessed one of the greatest snowfalls of its history.
That winter was special also for me and my colleagues,
because we had an insight about the possible mathematical scheme --
again, possible, possible mathematical scheme,
to conceive the occurrence of the new.
I remember that day because it was snowing,
so due to the snowfall, we were blocked, stuck in my department,
and we couldn't go home,
so we got another coffee, we relaxed
and we kept discussing.
But at some point -- maybe not that date, precisely --
at some point we made the connection
between the problem of the new
and a beautiful concept proposed years before
by Stuart Kauffman,
the adjacent possible.
So the adjacent possible consists of all those things.
It could be ideas, it could be molecules, it could be technological products
that are one step away
from what actually exists,
and you can achieve them through incremental modifications
and recombinations of the existing material.
So for instance, if I speak about the space of my friends,
my adjacent possible would be the set of all friends of my friends
not already my friends.
I hope that's clear.
But now if I meet a new person,
say Briar,
all her friends would immediately enter my adjacent possible,
pushing its boundaries further.
So if you really want to look from the mathematical point of view --
I'm sure you want --
you can actually look at this picture.
So suppose now this is your universe.
I know I'm asking a lot.
I mean, this is your universe. Now you are the red spot.
And the green spot is the adjacent possible for you,
so something you've never touched before.
So you do your normal life.
You move. You move in the space.
You have a drink. You meet friends. You read a book.
At some point, you end up on the green spot,
so you meet Briar for the first time.
And what happens?
So what happens is there is a new part,
a brand new part of the space,
becoming possible for you in this very moment,
even without any possibility for you to foresee this
before touching that point.
And behind this there will be a huge set of points
that could become possible at some later stages.
So you see the space of the possible is very peculiar,
because it's not predefined.
It's not something we can predefine.
It's something that gets continuously shaped and reshaped
by our actions and our choices.
So we were so fascinated by these connections we made --
scientists are like this.
And based on this,
we conceived our mathematical formulation for the adjacent possible,
20 years after the original Kauffman proposals.
In our theory -- this is a key point --
I mean, it's crucially based on a complex interplay
between the way in which this space of possibilities expands
and gets restructured,
and the way in which we explore it.
After the epiphany of 2012,
we got back to work, real work,
because we had to work out this theory,
and we came up with a certain number of predictions
to be tested in real life.
Of course, we need a testable framework
to study innovation.
So let me drive you across a few predictions we made.
The first one concerns the pace of innovation,
so the rate at which you observe novelties in very different systems.
So our theory predicts that the rate of innovation
should follow a universal curve,
like this one.
This is the rate of innovation versus time in very different conditions.
And somehow, we predict that the rate of innovation
should decrease steadily over time.
So somehow, innovation is predicted to become more difficult
as your progress over time.
It's neat. It's interesting. It's beautiful. We were happy.
But the question is, is that true?
Of course we should check with reality.
So we went back to reality
and we collected a lot of data, terabytes of data,
tracking innovation in Wikipedia, Twitter,
the way in which we write free software,
even the way we listen to music.
I cannot tell you, we were so amazed and pleased and thrilled
to discover that the same predictions we made in the theory
were actually satisfied in real systems,
many different real systems.
We were so excited.
Of course, apparently, we were on the right track,
but of course, we couldn't stop,
so we didn't stop.
So we kept going on,
and at some point we made another discovery
that we dubbed "correlated novelties."
It's very simple.
So I guess we all experience this.
So you listen to "Suzanne" by Leonard Cohen,
and this experience triggers your passion for Cohen
so that you start frantically listening to his whole production.
And then you realize that Fabrizio De André here
recorded an Italian version of "Suzanne,"
and so on and so forth.
So somehow for some reason,
the very notion of adjacent possible is already encoding the common belief
that one thing leads to another
in many different systems.
But the reason why we were thrilled
is because actually we could give, for the first time,
a scientific substance to this intuition
and start making predictions
about the way in which we experience the new.
So novelties are correlated.
They are not occurring randomly.
And this is good news,
because it implies that impossible missions
might not be so impossible after all,
if we are guided by our intuition,
somehow leading us to trigger a positive chain reaction.
But there is a third consequence of the existence of the adjacent possible
that we named "waves of novelties."
So just to make this simple, so in music,
without waves of novelties,
we would still be listening all the time to Mozart or Beethoven,
which is great,
but we don't do this all the time.
We also listen to the Pet Shop Boys or Justin Bieber -- well, some of us do.
(Laughter)
So we could see very clearly all of these patterns
in the huge amounts of data we collected and analyzed.
For instance, we discovered that popular hits in music
are continuously born, you know that,
and then they disappear, still leaving room for evergreens.
So somehow waves of novelties ebb and flow
while the tides always hold the classics.
There is this coexistence between evergreens and new hits.
Not only our theory predicts these waves of novelties.
This would be trivial.
But it also explains why they are there,
and they are there for a specific reason,
because we as humans display different strategies
in the space of the possible.
So some of us tend to retrace already known paths.
So we say they exploit.
Some of us always launch into new adventures.
We say they explore.
And what we discovered is all the systems we investigated
are right at the edge between these two strategies,
something like 80 percent exploiting, 20 percent exploring,
something like blade runners of innovation.
So it seems that the wise balance, you could also say a conservative balance,
between past and future, between exploitation and exploration,
is already in place and perhaps needed in our system.
But again the good news is now we have scientific tools
to investigate this equilibrium,
perhaps pushing it further in the near future.
So as you can imagine,
I was really fascinated by all this.
Our mathematical scheme is already providing cues and hints
to investigate the space of possibilities
and the way in which all of us create it and explore it.
But there is more.
This, I guess, is a starting point of something that has the potential
to become a wonderful journey for a scientific investigation of the new,
but also I would say a personal investigation of the new.
And I guess this can have a lot of consequences
and a huge impact in key activities
like learning, education, research, business.
So for instance, if you think about artificial intelligence,
I am sure -- I mean, artificial intelligence,
we need to rely in the near future
more and more on the structure of the adjacent possible,
to restructure it, to change it,
but also to cope with the unknowns of the future.
In parallel, we have a lot of tools,
new tools now, to investigate how creativity works
and what triggers innovation.
And the aim of all this is to raise a generation of people
able to come up with new ideas to face the challenges in front of us.
We all know.
I think it's a long way to go,
but the questions, and the tools,
are now there, adjacent and possible.
Thank you.
(Applause)